i'm from warren
does it work now ah great
perfect
um so yeah just to say thank you very
much for having me here
today i will talk about um consensus
based sampling so this is something that
we also discussed a little bit already
in the working groups over the past
weeks
and this is a collaboration with uh jose
carrillo urban vase and andrew stewart
and it's been really um
a great pleasure to
bring together at the same table both of
my mentors jose carrillo who was my phd
advisor and andrew stewart who was my
postdoc advisor at caltech
so this is really an outcome sort of
an intersection of different
topics and recent research that is very
much at the heart of this program as
well
okay so
this is a brief overview of what i will
talk about
today
and let's start with sort of the big
picture
so that i can introduce to you what is
this consensus-based
sampling method
um so
we really think of this as a very
generic
method for sampling from some target
distribution which might be gaussian or
also more general than that
but one really sort of important
application of this
is in the context of solving inverse
problems
and so here i'm writing a very sort of
general
inverse problem y equal to g of theta
plus some noise
and i'm sure a lot of you have already
seen this formulation
a couple of times now during the program
um so the g here is a forward map
which maps some parameters data to your
observation space
why is the the data that you that you go
out and measure
and then ether is a sub-noise which we
here assume to be gaussian distributed
um
and so there's two important questions
that you might
want to answer one is
so given this model so assuming that the
observations that i have are generated
in this way
what is the most likely theta what is
the most likely set of parameters given
by data right so this would be an
optimization problem
or also parameter calibration
another question i could ask is here's a
parameter theta
what is the probability that this
parameter gave rise to the data that i
observe so in other words i would like
to understand the the the distribution
of parameters
given the data
and so this would really then be
uncertainty quantification
and so this is where the something
methods come in
now in a lot of inverse problems that we
encounter in applications this forward
map jeep is g is very complicated or can
be very non-explicit also so we like to
think of it more like a black box
algorithm so you could think of for
example
some complicated weather model where you
have to
solve several coupled pdes with binary
conditions and initial conditions and so
on
and your parameters theta could be
something like a diffusion coefficient
that you don't know or like a boundary
condition that you don't know and
there's many other
sort of applications as well of course
but in that sense in in these
applications this forward map jeep can
be very expensive to evaluate so you
don't want to do that very often and
also because it's non-explicit in some
sense
diverges might not be available or they
might be available but very expensive to
calculate so ideally you would like to
do parameter calibration and uncertainty
quantification without having to
calculate the derivative of this forward
not g
and so one way of thinking about this is
the
bayesian
approach to endless problems
where you assume some prior distribution
of your data
and so the model
that you consider gave rise to your data
gives you a likelihood
and so then thanks to bayes theorem
you get a posterior distribution and now
if you assume that their prior is
gaussian
and your noise is gaussian
then that gives you a gaussian posterior
which would look uh something like this
right
and so in a generic way we can write
this as e to the minus f
where in this case f would be just a
quadratic function
but you can also think about of this of
course more generally now once you have
this expression you can simply forget
about this inverse problem application
if you like and just say well we have
this um probability distribution e to
the minus f
and i would like to either optimize so
find the maximum
of this distribution so the minimum of f
or i would like to sample from it
and so this corresponds to either
the the calibration
question or the sampling question
um
okay
so here i'm just mentioning a couple of
sort of recent work where
interacting particle systems turn out to
be very useful
to to address these to address these
questions
um
and i don't want to go too much into
detail here but maybe just the take-home
message
that using
interacting particle systems for example
for evolving samples so that you obtain
samples from the target distribution
that you're interested in
first of all allow you to
obtain methods that are parallelizable
since you can compute this forward map
sort of for
each of the particles separately and
that's usually the step that is very
costly
and also you can then look at the mean
field limits of these
particle systems
and can do analysis on these mean field
pdes and that usually gives you some
insights and also results such as
convergence and so on
so this just to say why interacting
particle system is sort of a very nice
tool
for um addressing
this question
so this work uh
or this method um for sampling which can
also be used for optimization actually
is came
or was was um
coming out of
this consensus-based optimization
algorithm
that was published not so long ago so
2017
and here the idea is the following
so
um
you set up
a particular evolution
where particles are driven towards a
weighted mean
and this weighted mean ambita
is just a re-weighting way with this
function f that you're actually
interested in so what we want to do here
is just minimize the f right
and so
by by putting the information of the f
into this this weighted mean
um
you hope that you converge
to an approximation of the minimum of
this function
um
and this is due to this result here that
i put at the bottom
so if
you look at the mean field equation for
this interacting particle system
and you look at just the normal mean
of the law for these particles
over time this will converge to some
value
and that value will depend on beta on
your choice of beta
and now if you take the limit as beta
goes to infinity then this
theta hat converges to the minimum of
your function
and so
even though in the algorithm you will
just take finite beta as long as your b
does large enough
this provides your way of approximating
the minimum of your target function
without
uh using any derivatives of f right
that's the that's one of the key points
um and then there's another sort of
important part here which is the the
noise term so you see that the magnitude
of the noise is modulated depending on
how far
this ensemble of particles is from the
weighted mean
so in other words so so this allows you
to
deal with functions that have a lot of
local minima that are not the global
minimum and you want to be able to get
out of these local minima in order to
find the global minimum so as long as
the particles don't agree with each
other you you keep adding noise
and the magnitude of the moist is sort
of proportional to how much they
disagree in some sense and for this to
work of course you have to start with
the particles that are spread enough at
the beginning
so
we looked at this and thought well
can we use this idea for sampling
um
and
so this is basically how how this
project came about now before i tell you
a bit more about the sampling
application
let me
mention why this works
so behind this is the laplace method or
laplacis principle
and this is simply saying the following
so if
i have my target function f
and now i define this this i beta is
just a re-weighting of any measure so i
i i take a measure i multiply it with e
to the beta f and then i we normalize
right
and so if i now look at integrals
against test functions for this
um for this
free weighting of measures
then i can look at the expansion in
pizza as beta goes to infinity and and
the really nice fact here is that
um
the first
the highest order term will be a
gaussian so this g here is a gaussian
and it sits exactly at theta star which
is the minimum of your f
and has then
one over beta times the inverse of the
hessian
at that minimum point
so it basically provides your gaussian
approximation of your functioning to the
minus f
and so this is this is then what's known
as the laplace approximation which is
basically just a gaussian right because
this is just a constant here
so this is the key
tool that we use
um
okay so i think with this we're ready to
go into
what exactly is is the method that we're
proposing
so this is now just to introduce the
notation
um so the m beta and the c beta
are the re-weighted
mean and covariance
and the m and the c is just the normal
mean and covariance of any of any
measure
and so
here's sort of a very simple
discrete time
sampling algorithm that you could
propose
and you see already that this looks
somehow similar to
the consensus-based optimization
the difference is that here we're adding
noise
with not just the difference between
the particle and the weighted mean but
instead the full weighted covariance
matrix
that's the first part
and the second part is that we have here
a parameter gamma
that we can tune and we also put the
parameter here so now i have three
parameters right i have the alpha the
beta and the gamma
and we even started with more parameters
like kind of the question that we wanted
to answer is
if i come up with a very general family
of
sampling algorithms or optimization
algorithms
what can i say about the parameter
choices that are most useful for rates
of convergence for the behavior of the
algorithm and so on
but i won't give you all the parameter
choices that we tried because these are
sort of the most useful ones
and again this is a derivative free
algorithm as it's just evolving a
particle or symbol
so
i will start by giving some analysis for
the gaussian case
so when this uh f is quadratic
just as a way of introduction and also
getting some idea of how this actually
works and then
um i will say a few things about the the
non-gaussian more general things that we
can say in the non-gaussian case
okay so what we would like to do of
course is choose our parameters in such
a way
that this
ensemble of particles actually converges
to being samples of
the target
e to the minus f
okay
so this is just to repeat the algorithm
so the first thing that you can do is is
do explicit calculations on the moments
and so this is now in the gaussian
setting right so f is quadratic
um
and so here
the weighted mean is just a and then the
weighted covariance can be also
expressed explicitly in terms of a
so that is very nice because now if you
write down the evolution of the moments
for this particle model
you can these are closed equations and
you can actually solve them and you can
study them and this is sort of very very
nice
and
so then you can ask okay which
parameters do i want to choose now so
that e minus f is actually a steady
state
and and this is the answer
so this is why from now on i will i will
always choose
the gamma to be
this guy
and so that also you already see
that
you know i was mentioning earlier that
in order for the laplace principle to
work you want the beats are very large
so if i take the beats are very large
then the gamma also becomes very large
and so what that means is that i'm
basically
rescaling the covariance
as i evolve the the particles
so preventing the collapse in some sense
right because we have seen that if we
don't do that then the particles
collapse and you actually obtain
an optimization method
um okay so
now
uh
this is the equation that you get on the
moments and as i said these are closed
equations so you can just plug these
formulas in
and and write them down and so you get
very nice
um rates of convergence for the moments
and so that means that if you start
gaussian
you will remain gaussian right so
gaussians are propagated by this method
um and
the evolution then of of the laws
corresponding to the particles is fully
characterized by
the moments and so this is basically
what gives you the rate of convergence
and you'll see that this is exponential
um
okay
and so the question is
what happens in the non-gaussian setting
right so for for gaussian settings this
all works very nicely yeah
so uh so so alpha can be any number
between minus one and one
and beta uh
so
just has to be positive and actually
bitter we would like to take very large
okay and then alpha
you know we were thinking of alpha as
being a kind of interpolation parameter
so taking it between zero and one
but you you know there's nothing that
stops you from taking it between zero
and minus one as well
but if you like just think of it being
between zero and one yeah and if you
optimize over alpha and b type do you
get something
very good
so this is exactly why um
we wanted to kind of keep all these
parameters involved because now you can
ask the question what gives me the best
rate of convergence right and there's
two observations you can immediately
make
one is that alpha equal to zero is
actually the best choice
right because that gives you the fastest
rate of convergence
and also bigger beta
gives you a faster rate of convergence
without limit actually so
the higher beta the faster
you will converge right
so so where do you pay you should pay
somewhere
it's for free
um
well this is for vouchers
so i think for gaussians you know you
can do many things where you will pay
this in a way as soon as you're
non-garcian
but anyway this serves as a good guiding
principle right you expect that some of
these things might still be true even if
you're not non-gaussian
okay
so with the previous formula uh for i'm
gonna see updates that involve a lot of
matrix inverse
large
is a new way to um
unless we know they are sparse or to
some student have some structure
otherwise
uh the inversion will be an actual cost
um
well you don't actually solve the moment
equations right you just you evolve the
particles themselves
for the particles you don't have to do
any matrix inversion
for c that's also the case c
the covers well you do have to evaluate
the covariance in order to evolve the
particles but
you don't have to invert it
but actually you know by
in the gaussian case you can actually
show
your lower bounds for the covariance and
upper bounds
because you can actually write down how
they evolve explicitly and so you know
what the condition number is and so you
know
i think sir
was the parameter in front of the
algorithm where is beta
so beta is just a re-weighting of the
means
um so so this is really the conceptual
key point here for this method that
you're not so you want to minimize f
but instead of setting up some kind of
gradient descent for f directly
instead you're putting the information
of the f into a weighted moment and then
in order to get there you increase this
this beta
you had another
inverse in your expression
on the next slide
there is a cn inverse there
here
yeah yes that's correct oh you said you
don't have to invert the matrix oh i
mean if you evolve the particles right
you don't have to explicitly compute the
now if you want to do analysis and you
want to write down the moment equations
then yes you do have to
um
oh i jumped over there yeah so
this parameter alpha
can actually be thought of as
the time discretization
so so this is
very nice if you if you think of alpha
as being e to the
minus some time step size
now if you take the time step size to
zero that will correspond to alpha going
to one
and so that actually corresponds to
converging to continuous in time
evolution here
and
um
so then what you get is this mckinsty
which looks structurally very similar of
course right
and
you see that you have also here the one
just pizza that blows up your
convergence
okay
um
yes and we know that if f is quadratic
so if the target is gaussian then e to
the minus f is a steady state
and we can also show
convergence for the continuum time model
but again this is all gaussian right
and this is exponential in time
and here you see now that you also
increase your rate of convergence as you
take pizza larger but not without limits
right this will always be
less than 1.
maybe what i should say also for this
rate and also for the rate in the
discrete time case
these rates are sharp so we actually
have upper and lower bounds yeah
short question against regarding the
race
it seems a bit unbelievable
all the way up
but i guess those rates
rate so are
say basically these are
for
the expectations of the moments but in
the mean field
sorry
are these rates for the mean field
setting this is for the mean field yes
this is all for the mean field
for the mean
your diffusion time becomes huge and you
immediately see the the minimum of your
of your loss and then you can go there
at one step yeah yeah no that's a that's
a very good point so here all the
analysis we did it on the mean field
equations and there's actually an
important question there sort of how to
bridge now
the convergence results that we know in
the mean field setting to what happens
on the particles
and i think that's very important
actually to to do
[Music]
so
if i write down the mean field equation
for this continuum time dynamics then i
get the following pd
and you see that in general this is not
a gradient flow necessarily right
so here there's no gradient flow
structure
um
yes and something to remark also is that
even if your target is non-garcian but
you start with the gaussian then you you
remain gaussian
so that that also means that you can
never sort of if you start from a
gaussian manifold you can never actually
exactly approximate like go converge to
your targets if your target is not
gaussian so what you will actually get
is a gaussian approximation of your
target and that's exactly what laplace's
method is giving you right
um
yes
is approximation of your target
distribution
i mean the mu infinity is is it is
approximation of the target distribution
right
but
is this approximation optimal in some
sense is this the one which would
minimize the chao divergence with
respect to the target distribution or
other things this one that's a very good
question
um
so first of all
i i will answer your question in
a moment
just a comment on this equation so this
this mu infinity here is the steady
state of the
evolution of this model right
so
we hope that this mu infinity
approximates e to the minus f in the end
and what you see from this formula is
that is gaussian so this method actually
always gives you a gaussian steady state
and this is the steady state equation no
matter what alpha so no matter whether
your discrete time or continuous time
and
even to to solve this new infinity
explicitly in the case where
your target is not gaussian
is actually very difficult
so if you're in the gaussian setting
then then this is explicit and that's
what i showed you earlier but um
yeah so this is not
straightforward to solving the
non-gaussian setting
now
how close is it
so so what this actually gives you
is
the so so as beta so this mu infinity
depends on beta right
and what we show and that that will come
in a few slides that as beta goes to
infinity then this mu infinity will
converge to the laplace approximation
of your um
target distribution of the e to the
minus f
now is it the closest one i mean we know
that in kl divergence
the closest gaussian that approximates
some probability measure is the gaussian
that has the mean and the covariance of
that probability measure right and so
here we're approximating e to the minus
f with the mean and the covariance
at that point theta star which is the
minimum of the f that's what the la plus
approximations
yeah i think that's the best answer i
can give you at this point but there
might still be some
sort of questions to be clarified here
actually
okay
so
now this is in the in the non-gaussian
setting
um
i kind of
uh
didn't put all the assumptions here
explicitly but i will
give more details on the assumptions
later on
but just to say that here
the only results that we were able to
prove
on both the mean and the covariance
for the non-gaussian setting
is in one dimension
and under the assumption
that
the hessian of your target
is uniformly bonded above and below
so this is a general assumption that um
you've probably seen in many sampling
algorithms
it is more general than gaussian but
it's not the most general thing that you
might hope for
now the reason why we only get
convergence rates in one dimension and
not in any dimension
is purely technical there is no sort of
methodological obstruction so so what we
need in order to get these estimates in
pizza is we need to actually work out
exactly the rates in beta
the higher order terms in the la plus
approximation
and if you're in more than one dimension
that just becomes incredibly tedious
so
um it's just kind of a question of
manpower and time rather than really the
the possibility of going higher
dimensional
um
yeah so first of all you so we know that
that this method converges to a gaussian
with mean and covariance depending on
pizza
and so this theta star here is the
minimum of f that we want and the c star
is the inverse of the hessian of the
target evaluated at this theta star
and we have the rate of convergence one
over beta here
um
and then i mean all these we
this convergence rate we got it for
initial gaussian
um because since we know that we're you
know the where we're going as a gaussian
and we know that
um
the method preserves
gaussians we might as well start as a
gap at a gaussian make our lives easier
um and then you just argue on the
moments
um
yes
what is k
k is a constant which depends on the
it's a constant which depends on the
condition number of your initial
covariance that you start with
um and also on your target yeah it's
kind of this k is kind of a comparison
between where you start and where you're
going in terms of the covariance
yeah
so if your solution is actually a
laplace then you don't need sampling
right and you can just use optimization
to get to the maximum posteriori and
then do expansion around the query
expansion and
yes so you're saying that if my target
discussion i don't actually need all of
this
yes i
i mean if you're if you have a target
that discussion there's many things you
can do right i mean there's many
variables
right okay you're saying your solution
is a plus approximation around theta
star which is
which is probably maximum
you can get to that without sampling
right you can use the optimization and
then expand around it and get you know
find a difference
let's talk afterwards about it
um
okay so another comment maybe that i've
just talked about something now but you
can also use this for optimization
and the only thing you have to do is
basically not blow up the covariance
along the flow to make sure that
particles collapse to a point and then
that point will actually be
the
theta star that you're looking for
and so here we just have the one minus
alpha squared instead of
another one plus beta
um
and i have to say that these rates are
not optimal
they give you convergence in
russellstein
but um
i'm pretty sure that we can do better
than than these rate and this p is just
something that comes out of the
calculation but
um we're not able to bootstrap on it in
the same way that we were able to do for
the sampling case so i think there's
still room of improvement for these
convergence rates here
um
okay now this is going to be interesting
if i can
show you some numerics yes
so you said
so with this choice you obtain an
optimization method
[Music]
why um because in that case you can
check
that the
steady state of the model is actually
the gaussian of uh covariance zero i
mean it's just a dirac and the direct
sits exactly at the fetus
or converges to the theta star i mean
this
is very similar to
what i showed you on the um
cbo method
i mean it's basically this argument
okay so let me let's see if i can show
you some
numerics
oh before i do that uh
okay so there's i should say all the
numerics that i show you have been done
by
urban vase
and we have a figshare online where you
can look at all sorts of different
um
versions of also other applications so i
just picked like one very simple one
that i want to show you here but i
encourage you to have a look there in
case you want to know more
so this has become a kind of benchmark
toy problem for solving inverse problems
so just a 1d
elliptic binary value problem
where you have an unknown diffusion
coefficient and an unknown boundary
condition and given theta 1 and theta 2
you can actually solve this explicitly
so this is very nice right
so you can write down this the solution
p
and now this becomes your forward map g
is just a function of these thetas just
fix two points where you collect data
and you corrupt them a little bit with
noise
and then you can plot
how your target function f
looks like
and then um test
your method on it so let me see if i
have
uh the simulations for that
something
i might not actually have this one here
ah okay well let me show you the
optimization one instead sorry
so what you what you see here is that
basically
uh i should have put the image where you
have i yeah i put the wrong image here
so basically the samples collapse
uh very quickly to the region where you
see most of the mass and then you can
compare that to
several other methods that have came out
recently
um and compare the rate of convergence
there
okay
so
some of the sort of typical
functions that are very difficult for
optimization methods are these functions
that have a lot of local minimizers and
these consensus-based techniques are
very good specifically at overcoming
that challenge
and so two choices are this ackly
function and restriction
you don't actually need to know at the
look at the whole formula of this i mean
just look at the the pictures here the
global minimum is where this um
crosses
and
then you see that it has a lot of local
minima kind of like an
egg shell
um
and so
let me just show you some simulations
for that since i
put them here
you see that the
[Music]
red cross
is the weighted mean
let's play that again
and something that you may also notice
is that we're actually changing the beta
along the evolution
um so you know the kind of analysis that
i showed you is for fixed beta but if
you play around with this you actually
see that you would like i mean you would
like your pizza to be large
um
and so if you increase the pizza
along your evolution
then that really helps
and so here
what we did is use the effective sample
size as a guidance for how to choose how
to fix the pizza
but there's no analysis that we have
done on this so there's kind of a very
interesting question here you know why
is this the good choices there may be a
better choice like what would be a good
choice for an adaptive pizza
for this method
and then
just maybe show you one other one
yeah so you see that
particles get stuck a little bit in the
local minima but then they get out
and they find um the global
uh
position
okay
so now let me show you sort of an
overview
because this has been probably a lot of
different equations so
just to summarize
um so here this this k0
is sort of the comparison between your
initial covariance and the target
covariance so here this is now the
gaussian case i will sort of give you
the summary of the gaussian case and
then the summary of the
beyond gaussian case setting
and so
all of these rates that we obtained for
the sampling and the optimization case
they're sharp in the sense that we have
upper and lower bounds for them
um
and yeah as i already mentioned you see
that
choosing alpha equal to zero is actually
the best choice for the discrete
setting
here
um
okay and the same also for the
optimization
and so just as a summary
[Music]
we get algebraic convergence for
optimization and exponential convergence
for sampling
and those rates in sampling are also
i mean in the gaussian case analogous to
what is known for ensemble common
methods like ensemble coming in division
and ensemble common sampling
we have sharp convergence rates and
yeah smaller alpha is better
um
yeah i also mentioned that
yeah larger better larger beta is better
now let me mention something about
the steady states so
actually any dirac measures also steady
state
um and so
you know what you in addition to the
gaussian that you're actually looking
for and so if you would start at the
d-rack then you wouldn't move
but what you can show is that if you
started something that is not a direct
right then you converge not to a direct
but
to the
targets that you're actually interested
in
um
now beyond the gaussian case
um so this is the assumption that we're
working with
um
[Music]
and
for the for the results that we have in
one dimension we have actually an
additional assumption that
the f cannot grow more than e to the x
squared
and it's the vertices as well
um
and so you see again that we get
a debrie grades for optimization and
then exponential rates for the sampling
and this is where this um n to the minus
p and t to the minus p
uh come in and and these are definitely
not optimal so here we were not
we're not yet fully satisfied with what
we were able to obtain on the rates
um but apart from that
i think this is one of the sort of
strong points of this method that you
can actually prove something about the
rates of convergence beyond just the
gaussian setting
um
okay so some comments on steady states
um so what this method gives you is
basically a steady state whose mean is
close to the minimizer of f
and for large pizza it converges to four
for beta going to infinity it converges
to the minimizer of f
and this is actually true in any
dimension and here we have one over beta
rates regarding any dimension
now the other statements are just in one
dimension
so we get
the steady state that is arbitrary close
to the laplace approximation
of the targets this is what this method
is giving you
for beta sufficiently large
of course
and then i already mentioned this mu
infinity is a steady state for all the
different parameter choices that you
might want to make
okay
and so just as a takeaway
yeah so the the plus approximation the
key principle sort of that you re-weight
any measure by e to the minus pizza
f and then this approximates the direct
sitting at the minimum
yeah so if you rescale your covariance
with the right factor then this allows
you to recover
an approximation of the
target e to the minus f
and then if you don't want
to sample but to optimize
you leave out the factor one plus beta
um
okay and we're able to get rates beyond
the gaussian setting
so
um
yeah this is just an overview as i said
like because we have this entire
particle system i mean this is true for
all these methods that use interacting
particle systems
um they're nicely parallelizable if this
forward map is very expensive to
to evaluate and we we do all the
analysis in the mean field perspective
all of this is derivative free so this
is very useful for these very expensive
inverse problems
we have exponential convergence for
sampling
and this method is also a fine invariant
which basically means that
if you
apply
and a fine transformation to the input
data
so the the measure where you start and
also
your targets
and then you run the model is the same
as if you run the model
and then you push forward with the same
a fine transformation
and so what that allows you to do in
some way
is um
yeah that's one way of thinking about
why
you get convergence rates
that are independent of the target in
the gaussian setting because that allows
you to kind of rescale
the the covariance to be identity by
applying such and a fine transformation
um and
there's a very nice work on this by
alfredo camuno anigo nicolas noskin and
sebastian reich
which i cited here so if you'd like to
know more about
these properties then i encourage you to
look there
and there's many open questions actually
in this general area of course but i
just listed like a couple here for this
specific problem
um yeah one is the question of adaptive
pizza if we can say anything about about
that
then proving convergence on the particle
level and also the approximations
between the particle level and the
um mean fields equations
um and then
if you can do anything about the
sampling error
so you know one also recent paper that
came out a calibrate emulate sample
i think it's a very nice idea where you
say well i have some sampling method
like this one
that gives you some approximate samples
of your target
um
and
now you can take these
approximate samples to create a
surrogate model for your forward map g
and then use a gaussian process emulator
to sample more cheaply
from your surrogate targets
um and so you can think of this method
kind of plugging in
as the first step in here
um
okay so this is all
that i wanted to say and
yeah thank you very much
yeah thank you very much for the very
nice talk um i've got a question does
this method possess the subspace
property meaning that the ensemble does
not leave the initial subspace yes
exactly yes exactly thanks to this
finite variance yes okay so your
underlying assumption was then that the
initial covariance is invertible or
something like that such that you can
actually get the hessian of the
function f in the end
but the initial um the initial ensemble
that the covariance of that ensemble is
invertible so basically that you already
covered the whole space that was an
underlying assumption yes yes yes yes
that's right yes and it makes up like
you would like to start with something
that's actually quite spread like spread
enough in the space so that your
particles explore enough initially yeah
that's very important and that
also turns up in the rates actually in
this k0 and the k because that's exactly
comparing the initial covariance to the
target covariance explicitly in the
gaussian case and that's exactly where
that shows up okay thank you yeah
any other questions
[Laughter]
um yeah thank you for talk so i have
actually have two questions so then uh
there's a naive one do you use uh
how do you use particles to compute
things like m of beta and c of theta do
you use some kind of
uh like crowd ac estimators or these
kind of approximations or is there any
direct way to do that
um i actually have a slide i put in the
appendix on this
so there you go
um
so you basically just uh work with the
empirical measures on the particles so
like the mean field equations that i
showed you
you can just approximate the integrals
by sums
um and then you have so the you know
these are coupled
equations for the particles and the
coupling happens exactly through the
means right
thank you so another question is if you
have a very highly in non-convex
pleasure how do you fix that
because you're always
remaining a gaussian
is there do you have any idea to
uh what do you mean
if you if your target is highly
non-complex then but your
but your dynamics
preserve a gaussian
so do you have any ideas on how to
fix that difference
using the landscape of the potential
uh no that's a that's a very good
question i mean you know what this
method is going to give you is only
gaussian approximations all the time so
of course if your target is
not as gaussian
it is very non-gaussian then those
approximations might not be very good
so that was exactly this question of you
know can you do better by somehow
correcting the samples well that's a
very important question
and so you motivated this in the
beginning by saying this is for
expensive functions
and
in case of expensive functions that the
usual
tests are you know well you have to
minimize the number of calls
and know that for 2d action or streaking
they usually need a few dozen calls
right let's say 30 or so
uh do you think your method can be
competitive in that confining for
example the the peak
with just a few dozen calls
um
i'm not sure on the exact numbers in
that
case but
hundreds of articles and you know and
several steps right so that was more
like thousands
um
so what i can tell you is that this
method actually gives you
very good approximations with comparably
a lot less particles than what you would
need for example in mcmc methods
um
also
if your forward map is very if your f is
very expensive to evaluate then of
course you would like your
number of particles to be very small
because
that
tells you how many times you have
computed the f in in s and for the means
and the covariance
um
but all the analysis we did is in the
mean field setting right
so now on the one hand you want to take
few particles because of the more if if
your f is very expensive to to evaluate
on the other hand everything i just told
you is for the mean field equations so
there's there's clearly a gap right and
so i think
there is some important follow-on work
that should happen
um
looking at
exactly those questions in the
for the
poker plank equation that is satisfied
by the empirical distribution of the
particles
right
so yeah
maybe just as a follow-up on this
um i'm very happy to report also that
this just got accepted this week
so you know this is very fresh so i
think there's actually i mean this is
some very important
question there to answer and i think
there's a couple of other questions and
i hope there will be follow-on work
going in that direction
so uh i think global optimization is
just very difficult problem
by itself so uh just for the combat
setting
empirically clear the last example is
entirely highly non-complex so they were
able to convert so which means there is
a potential it just the analysis
probably
hasn't got
am i understanding it's correct yes yes
i mean this with this method as well as
as far as i understand many other
sampling methods there's often a very
big gap between what you observe works
and then what you're able to prove about
the behavior right so we were kind of
very happy to even just go beyond
gaussians as long as you have uniform
upper and lower bounds on the hessian
whereas
in practice you know
it seems like this is actually doing
very well and
um
compared to the osama camus sampler for
example
um
also doing very well
so
yeah i think if there's anything that we
could say
for more complicated problems that
actually appear in applications i think
that would be a huge
step forward
i think particle level proof will be
definitely the way to go because that
really tells you if you'll converge to
the global minimum
i just wonder that
because you advertise this method as a
great and free so if it's not hard to
compute the gradient how does this
method compare
ah
i i would assume that gradient-based
methods would do better
okay in that case in higher dimensions
yeah that's right yeah that's right
all right okay thanks thank you again
uh yes thanks for the talk um uh so i
was uh
i was trying to summarize what you get
in the case of optimization so you have
the method desired is a derivative free
and you have uh
so convergence to the
so you said the steady state is a a is a
jack
right
uh direct at the minimizer of f right
and
well well no
you have you have a target well you have
a dirac as a target
and that sits at some point that depends
on beta and as beta goes to infinity
then that point converges to the
minimize of f all right
okay and the rate that you showed
in the last slide before going to the
the numerical section
this one
i know before
before
uh no after that i think
the last slide before the numerical
for this one
yes ah this rates yes so
what does it mean
uh
so as i said i don't i don't think these
rates are optimal uh yes but i just want
to understand
right
so it does okay
and i'm happy also to chat in more
detail and show you
how exactly that computation goes for
this all right and also why we get stuck
here right if anyone can tell me how we
can bootstrap these limits i would be
very happy yeah okay okay all right
thanks thanks
let's move on to the next talk